♪♪
>>> So some doctors are calling
for more research into the side
effects of very popular diabetes
and weight loss drugs like
ozempic and wegovy.
They say new side effects may be
emerging as the demands
skyrocket.
Meg Terrel is here.
>> Reporter: We know these drugs
work by mimicking a hormone in
the gut to stimulate the body to
produce insulin and slow hunger
and slows the stomach from
emptying.
It's the last thing that doctors
are focussed on now.
They talked with patients who
caused stomach paralysis or
gastroperisis.
That can cause severe vomiting
and gnaw sa.
Gi side effects are known side
effects of these medicines.
44% of patients on wegovy which
is a higher doze of ozempic for
weight loss.
But the stomach emptying effect
is something that they mention
in the drug's label but only to
warn patients it can affect if
they're taking other drugs the
metabolism of those drugs as
well.
Not that it can cause this
effect.
The fda said it received some
reports of stomach paralysis
among patients taking the
medicines they don't know if the
medicines caused this.
They said in some cases that
hadn't stopped even after
patients stopped taking the
medicine.
And the American society of
anesthesiologists warned
patients should stop taking
these medicines if they're
having elected surgery.
This is something that is known
but doctors are saying we don't
understand this effect well
enough and patients should be
aware of it.
If they're having severe
vomiting that's not a good
thing.
>> What are the companies
saying?
They were saying nshl initially,
this could be some of the side
effects.
But not this severe.
>> They said these drugs and the
class of medicines has been on
market.
They say there's something like
9.5 million patient years of
experience with these medicines.
So they note that this can
happen, they don't say it's a
severe side effect of the drug
and haven't been proven to be